وينضم الينا في الاستديو ازاميلا جمال
بتوما جمال مرحبا واهلا بك
شو مال بعد الدبابات الثقيله اليوم سيصل
الى اوكرانيا الصواريخ بعيده المدى هل
نتوقع ردا روسيا على هذا المستوى الجديد
من الدعم الغربي لاوكرانيا
الصواريخ الجديده هذا المستوى الجديد من
التسليح اذا اضفناه الى الدبابات الثقيله
سيعقد مهمات القوات الروسيه سيبطل امد هذه
المعركه هذه المواجهه وسيستنزف اكثر
القوات الروسيه لن نتحدث عن هزيمتها لان
ذلك صعب جدا من الصعب جدا ان تهزم قوه
النوويه لكن بالتاكيد انها ستغسل الكثير
ما يجري حاليا هو ان روسيا تعد خطتها
لمعركه
تبدا ابتداء من الربيع تستفيد منها من
الاخطاء التي ارتكبت خلال طوال هذه السنه
القوى الغربيه
وطبعا النداء اسال اوكرانيه المتكرره فهمت
ان من اجل مواجهه هذه الخطه العسكريه
وارباكها ربما تحتاج الى هذا النوع من
الاسلحه الذي يمكن ان يضرب خطوط الامدادات
والتخيره علما ان همم هذه الصواريخ لا
يتعدى مداها 150 كم همم اوكرانيا تحتاج
الى صواريخ ابعد اذا ارادت ان تطال
الاراضي الروسيه وهذا طبعا مما يشكل خطرا
يخاف منه ايضا الغرب في حال اي انفلات في
هذه المواجهه علما ان هناك تقارير تتحدث
عن ان روسيا همم تجهز منظومه دفاعيه
لاحتمال همم امر مثل هذا طيب جمال ايضا
اسرائيل
يعني نتنياهم قال بان هناك يدرس عمليه
ارسال مساعدات عسكريه الى اوكرانيا
هو نتيجه الضغوط التي تتعرض لها اسرائيل
واخرها خلال هذه الزياره التي يجراها وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي الحلفاء الغربي يريدون
من خراطا اكبر في هذه المواجهه العسكريه
ايضا همم والاوكرانيون يريدون منها
انخراطا اكبر التصريحات التي ادلى بها
نتنياهو يتعهدت لحد الان لا نعرف هل سيعطي
مثلا المنظومه الدفاعيه التي تطلبها
اوكرانيا منظومه القبه الحديديه ام سيكتفي
بمساعده عسكريه محدوده علما ان ما يطلبه
الاوكرانيون من اسرائيل هو المنظومه
الدفاعيه منظومه القبه الحديديه ويطلبون
منها ايضا خبره تكنولوجيه في ما يتعلق
بالطائرات الايرانيه بدون طيار لانها تملك
خبرات لمواجهه هذه الطائرات التي همم
تستعملها روسيا في اوكرانيا باعتبار
المواجهه المفتوحه بين ايران وبين اسرائيل
المشكله انها تخاف من اغضاب روسيا وهي
خليفه ايضا لانها تحاول ان تمسك العصا من
الوسط هناك علاقه خاصه تربط بين نتنياهو
بين بوتين بوتين هنا بعد فوزه بالانتخابات
التشريعيه وكانت هناك مباحثات بين الكوهن
ولافروب مؤخرا هاتفيه بمعنى انها خصوصا هو
خوف هي علاقات خاصه وخوف ايضا لا ننسى ان
روسيا توجد على حدود اسرائيل في سوريا وهي
من يراقب الاجواء همم السوريه روسيا وتسمح
لاسرائيل بضرب
المنشات العسكريه او التحركات العسكريه
الايرانيه تسمح لها بضربها اذا تغيرت
المعادله ربما قد يتعاقد الامر على امن
اسرائيل ايضا فيما يتعلق بالقبه الحديديه
هناك تحفظات من هذه المنظومات الدفاعيه
اذا استعملت في اوكرانيا يمكن ان يجري
تحليلها من طرف الخبراء الروس وبالتالي
تنتقل نتائج هذا الفحص التقني الى اعداء
اسرائيل في المنطقه اي حزب الله وايران
وتصبح صواريخهم اكثر فعاليه عندما تقصف
اسرائيل شكرا جزيلا لك ازمير الجمال